cardi B got in trouble you sure about
this oh yeah the audience is like no we
didn't someone actually gasped go ahead
someone actually gas SAS kept that woman
right there a woman cast yes party B our
TVs in trouble she went oh my god you
gasp easily that was crazy
well they're all out of starburst take
it easy
ya know cardi B is fine she just got in
some trouble that's all all right now
she's doing this no one's done this in a
hundred years
get her a turn-of-the-century fan whoa
whoa
anyway cardi B has been out have you
heard this in New York City cardi B has
been arrested for ordering an attack in
a strip club
yeah yeah she's been charged with two
counts of trying to get on the Supreme
Court so apparently the new standard now
you do that you're like
speaking of which harvard law school
just announced that Brett Kavanaugh will
not be teaching there next winter after
after hearing this Cavanaugh said but it
says so on my calendar president Trump
says that the new trade deal with Canada
and Mexico proves that tough talk works
yeah
then Trump called German Chancellor
Angela Merkel and said what's up [ __ ]
we talked about that one backstage and I
said and I said I think they're gonna
love it yeah yeah I I don't think we
talked about it long enough no no and I
was wrong
let me repeat Angela Merkel said that
was the problem there Andy all right
they didn't hear me yeah I didn't
enunciate that's right you're gonna like
this one I only got a few the the
European Union is asking the nation of
Macedonia to change its name yeah now
citizens will vote on one of three
options North Macedonia new Macedonia or
Ashley good enough I'm grading on a
curve now Hey
it was just reported that in Malaysia a
man's been living in the airport for
seven months yeah good news is today his
connecting flight on United finally
arrived
now a smart man would get out there but
I never said I was smart did I I think
you're gonna really like this last one
true story a man was arrested at a
Walmart after offering to pay two
hundred thousand dollars for a small
child yes also arrested the child's
mother who said hell yes two hundred
thousand dollars my mother would have
taken so much less for me in 1972 it
should have been like what four cans of
mayonnaise yeah take it don't be sad I
was a really shitty little kid hi how
are you
you